hey everyone this is John Roker with
Collider with the lovely Chloe Bennett
from this awesome new animated film
abominable Chloe this I just finished
watch this last night I stopped crying
maybe this morning and okay what a very
sweet and fantastic film that also has
some an incredible emotional journey
that you go on as a character you know
what I think it's just I grew up with
six brothers and I was constantly
outvoted when it came to movies so I
never really got to watch I mean I've
never seen any princess movie and from
what I saw I didn't really relate to the
idea that a happy ending for a woman was
kind of finding their prince charming
and that was ultimately the end of the
story and for this film so much is so
much of it is about her like this young
girl dealing with grief and dealing with
how to like you know it's such an
organic and authentic version of a young
person not knowing what to do and the
the kind of answer of the movie or the
journey is her going I this is something
I feel I don't know if this is right I
feel like I'm worried vomiting but this
is is this okay is this even okay and
and it's such an honest portrayal of how
I think young people should and you know
you know deal with things like distance
but feeling distant from family feeling
like isolated feeling left out dealing
with grief and I think such it's just
like an honest portrayal of that yeah
there's that moment with you and many
where you're saying yeah with the
character of Yi and she says like I I
don't know why I'm busy all the time I
just know I need to be yeah so do you
think young girls watching this maybe
who've experienced some kind of loss and
a lot do you feel like this is something
that will really speak to them I think
it'll speak to the you know I think that
the it's crazy that this there's been a
gap in the market for just showing a
female character that's one of color but
also that's one where the end goal isn't
finding a prince charming and the end
goal you know the whole journey is all
is about her getting this you know Yeti
home but in reality it's really about
them teaching each other what home is
home is and is feeling at home with
yourself at peace with yourself and
understanding your how you can
communicate with your loved ones it's
kind of about finding herself and them
in a way and almost finding a pseudo
family - yes the one she's distant from
yeah at that time yeah back to connect a
lot of it is just you know surrounding
yourself with you know going on a
journey of self-discovery and what that
means to you know someone that age and
and dealing with grief and like a really
kind of as like a spunky tomboy curious
like stubborn young woman and it's
important for you know young girls and
boys to see people on screen who aren't
perfect because if we keep this kind of
Instagram version of ourselves or like
it's everything's curated and everything
is seen as one way that's a really
dangerous place whereas this film kind
of lives in that spot of it's a stunning
visual film but it's really like a very
universal story of feeling not good
enough but being determined to be hurt
being herself that's what I love about
her as a characters she's she's in the
movie she's like I'm a self-proclaimed
loner that's the difference and she's
okay with being different it doesn't
make her not long for more right but
she's okay with who she is and she wants
to be better and I think anyone can
hopefully really do that it's a great
message yeah I gotta wrap up I have to
ask one last question game of Collider
one word to describe the future other
this upcoming season of agents of shield
one unique word to town yeah that's
stupid
hairspray okay there's a meet word arts
that's Chloe Bennet for this upcoming
film ababil Thank You Chloe
John Roca for Collider